ah Brent you all right buddy all right
is a relative term hey guys I'm Brent
rose writer and now blood donor and
today we're testing the brand new GoPro
Hero 7 black we're testing it really
really thoroughly so this is the new
hero 7 black as you can tell it looks a
lot like the hero 6 block in fact it's
got the same image sensor the exact same
body they're both waterproof to 33 feet
but also there are some other two
differences and that's what we're gonna
focus on today so the bailer feature
here is the improved electronic image
stabilization mode which GoPro is
calling hyper smooth now it works across
just about all of the frame rates in the
camera but it does crop about 10% off of
the image GoPro saying it offers gimbal
like stabilization inside the camera
body that is a bold ass claim which
we're gonna test last for now though we
can say it's definitely an improvement
over last year's image stabilization
here you're looking at the taller 4x3
format it's good for biking because you
get a lot of the bike in and you also
get a lot of the trail now pay attention
to the horizon line you can see in the
new version there's way way less balance
you can see it working especially well
on the smaller bumps that just rattle
things a bit it's not night and day but
it's definitely the movement over last
year
the difference is a little bit less
obvious in this water slide but if you
look again at the horizon and the trees
in the background and even at my face
you'll see that there's not quite as
much bounce oh yeah that's some good
spray oh my god why am I doing this this
clip was shot in 4k at 60 frames a
second which the hero six here cannot
stabilize it now when we switch over the
hero 7 you'll notice there's almost no
vibration you'll see it here in the
black bar at the top and the orange
slides as I'm going down it really does
a great job of minimizing those little
shakes hand held is actually a very
realistic use case because a lot of
people take their GoPros while traveling
and they just want to shoot the sights
and you can see the new version actually
has way way reduced to shake and now
we're getting into testing against the
sony x3000 v which is the only action
camera that has optical image
stabilization so it's uncropped in its
best-in-class
the hero 7 really does a pretty good job
against the sony there's a bit more
bounce with the gopro you can see a bit
more up and down movement but the sony
has a little bit more wobble that's
exaggerated in this bike test but
honestly that's not fair to the Sony
because Sony's bike mount was just a lot
looser than the one that GoPro makes for
all of the handheld tests I was holding
both cameras in the same hand so there
should be analogous in general I'd say
they both do a really good job here
eliminating little subtle shakes the
next feature is called time warp which
takes last year's time lapse video
feature and merges it with hyper smooth
so you've got stabilized time lapse
videos
this is something smartphones have been
able to do for a while but with this
wide GoPro lens it actually looks really
really good
the stabilization works the Verizon
stays pretty steady and generally it's
pretty awesome feature basically just
makes the time lapses way way better and
it's definitely an improvement over the
last year but people actually want to
listen to what's happening on your GoPro
you'll be happy to know that the mics
have been redesigned the base is way
more full the mids are a little bit
lifted in general it sounds clearer no
it's still not as good as a camera that
isn't waterproof but for waterproof
camera it definitely sounds better than
the last version how's the audio let's
see how's the audio closer to the edge
than I wanted to be I was close from the
edge then I wanted to be high notes
lalalalala no notes lalalalala high
notes
lalalalala no notes lalalalala now here
it is against the Sony which remember
has no waterproof membrane on its
microphone so you would expect the GoPro
to sound a lot worse but really it's
pretty comparable
and now back to the two GoPros
[Music]
if you're always doing it for the gram
you'll be happy to know that vertical
video is now supported now you are
always able to shoot like this but that
meant you have to rotate the video in
post-production now the way the shots
come off the card are exactly the way
you want them to look up next is super
photo the new Auto mode for stills that
basically applies intelligent settings
on the fly so if it's got a lot of
dynamic range it may go ahead and put in
HDR mode or if it's a dark scene it
might do some noise reduction
that's all good in theory but ultimately
remember we've got the same image sensor
in here as the hero 6 so photos don't
really look all that different
personally I try to always shoot in RAW
because you have way more flexibility in
post but if you're wanting to just
transfer it straight from the camera to
your phone and pop it on to Instagram
this could come in handy GoPro is also
revamp the UI to make it a little bit
more phone like so now a lot of things
are accomplished by swiping it puts some
of the more frequently used features
front and center but for people we've
coming from previous versions of GoPro
it might take a little bit of relearning
the 7 black is also the first GoPro to
support live-streaming to a number of
platforms including YouTube Facebook
basically anything that has an open API
you can stream directly from your GoPro
to it now we weren't able to test this
because while we're reviewing this this
whole thing was under embargo so we
couldn't publicly post something online
but in theory that's an awesome feature
I like the idea of being out there on my
mountain bike and live broadcasting my
own injuries now let's get back to the
somewhat outrageous claim that you can
get gimbal like stabilization in this
little camera body now you can't say
something like that and not expect
people to test it out so we did this is
the hero 7 black with hyper smooth
compared with the hero 6 black in GoPros
own climber crib this is the view from
the grip and you can see it's very very
smooth look at the power lines in the
background
there's definitely more bounce with the
hero seven and black you can see it's
cropped in a lot more on my face and
there's definitely a lot more within the
background this is the Karma grip on the
chest mount and on another chest mount
is the hero seven black it actually does
really well in this mountain bike test
you can see how much my arm is bouncing
but the horizon is very very smooth very
impressive this is running both cameras
in the same hand the gimbal is just
extremely smooth the hero 7 black it's
doing a pretty good job but there's
definitely a lot more bounce what I'm
seeing is that the hero 7 does a really
good job of eliminating vibration and
subtle shake but when it comes to larger
movements it definitely can't compare to
a gimbal so after three weeks of testing
the hero 7 black in different situations
right before we were done with this
video
GoPro sent me a firmware update the
final one the camera will ship with
which it claims improves the image
stabilization even more now obviously we
couldn't retest everything but I did do
a quick test against the gimbal again
and honestly I'm not seeing much of a
difference from what we saw before you
can see the big bumps on the right and
it's nice and smooth on the left because
it's a gimbal maybe it's further
improved but it's still not a gimbal so
what did we learn here today
well the hyper smooth feature is cool
it's definitely a step above last year's
image stabilization but you can't say
that it has gimbal like stabilization
when it doesn't have gimbal like
stabilization but it does compare pretty
favorably to the current king of smooth
the sony x 3000 the time-warp video is a
really cool feature and the improved
microphones actually make a huge
difference in a lot of different
scenarios so if you're considering
buying your first action camera this is
a really good way to go the image
quality is excellent the stabilization
is nice and it's actually very intuitive
especially with the screen in the back
if you've already got a hero 5 or 6 and
you can get a decent price for them then
yeah it actually might be worth the
upgrade what do you think let us know in
the comments below subscribe to Wired if
you haven't already with all that being
said there's really only one thing left
to do
[Music]
[Applause]